foreign
and have a look at this top secret
project we've been working on it's
finally time to push the button and put
the mighty shrink laser to the test
I'm ready
we did it it worked right under our
noses there's so much hidden that we
never get to see with our own eyes
entire Realms of bizarre structures and
outlandish creatures
what a magical place this is a forest of
slime molds single-celled organisms that
work together and form fungus-like
structures
but we don't have time to hang out with
these calm fellows any longer
now we're in the Kingdom of the mighty
tardigrade don't disturb them in their
death-like Slumber don't worry though
they'll wake up once the conditions are
less rough
didn't mean to get in the way your cells
are hustling to keep you alive
coordinating myriads of proteins this
might be the weirdest place yet with no
up or down there's way too much going on
better move on
now we're inside one of the parts that
allow you to watch this video the
structure of a microchip is so small it
nearly Breaks the Rules of the quantum
Realm
wait
things happening
these Hidden Worlds are all part of our
12023 shuben era Canada
this time you can join us on a journey
through the microcosm with each turn of
the page you will reveal a new world you
didn't know existed right beneath your
feet
you know the drill by now as always it's
a super high quality calendar very shiny
and only available for a short time we
also have a few special deals for you in
our shop
the calendar is a true piece of quartz
Gazette you can take home with you and
we say this every year but it's true
every calendar purchase directly
supports what we do here at kotskazat
and that's not just creating videos but
sparking curiosity all around the world
so because of you we can spread
knowledge and ignite an appreciation for
space nature and life in people
everywhere thank you so much for making
this possible have a wonderful
12023 see you down in January
foreign
[Music]